toute une époque des Solex
le repropriétaire c'est Jean-François
Venon quand il ne Chine pas il reçoit
les membres de son association créant
2005 tous des mordus moyenne d'âge 70
ans j'ai connu le seul à 17 ans parce
que en fait j'habitais c'était isolé
donc pour se déplacer pour sortir un peu
c'était plus facile qu'à vélo donc là
j'ai
connu ce sentiment de liberté et que
j'ai toujours jamais oublié
[Musique]
mais bon ça suit derrière
matinée frisquette malgré les rayons du
soleil un petit décrassage s'impose
avant la route des randonnées
chaque adhérent à son Solex
l'association on a ne fournit pas de
Solex chacun est propriétaire de son
matériel
et quand on fait nos randonnées on a
toujours il y a personne qui reste sur
le bord de la route on a un camion balai
qui suit et on fait autour de 110 km sur
la journée
110 115 ça dépend des années suivant le
parcours
après cette courte virée printanière qui
n'était qu'une mise en chambre pour des
moteurs endoloris nous retrouvons
Jean-François venant dans son garage
parmi ses protégés chaque Solex a une
histoire
1962 l'année de son certificat d'études
primaire
c'est mon premier engin motorisé que
j'ai eu mes parents m'ont dit si tu as
ton certificat d'études on t'achète un
Solex le soleil ça c'est un engin qui
est très facile d'entretien qui
consomment très peu on consomme un litre
et demi d'essence au sang qui était
passionné par la mécanique et je suis
rentré en apprentissage de mécanique et
après je me suis mis à mon compte
jusqu'à tant que je sois à la retraite
j'ai fait toute ma carrière dans la
mécanique j'en ai une trentaine en état
plus tous ceux que j'ai à remettre en
état je sais pas exactement combien mais
un nombre important
au fil du temps Jean-François venant est
devenu l'Europe propriétaire d'une
impressionnante collection de cyclos et
de Solex parmi ces modèles une petite
merveille de 1949
ce Solex là quand on l'a trouvé il était
rouillée de partout il a été refait de A
à Z peinture poncée et les gens repolir
les jantes le moteur démonté tout était
oxydé il a été refait complet de A à Z
ça c'est un 45 et ils l'ont appelé 45
parce que le moteur faisait seulement 45
cm3 c'est une très belle pièce de
collection ça c'est très rare on dirait
un tas de ferraille il n'en est rien
rouillé et exposé aux intempéries ces
modèles hors d'âge attend de d'être
sorti de leur léthargie grâce à des
bases expertes ces engins pourront
retrouver une seconde jeunesse et selon
ses gaiement dans de folles randonnées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]